on va faire ensemble le classement de
vos courts métrages préférés sur ma
chaîne youtube c'est parti pour ce faire
c'est très simple dans les commentaires
vous dit votre court-métrage préférez
votre deuxième puis troisième simple
facile voici la liste pour ceux qui ont
oublié technophobes mon premier court
métrage l'histoire de quelqu'un qui
devient allergique à la technologie le
lecteur une histoire sombre de
commentaires plus en pendant un repas de
famille la cartouche le saviez vous à la
fin il ya une musique de big flo et oli
le déménagement suite à un bug deux
inconnus se retrouve à faire pas un
déménagement lunaire deux frères que
tout oppose réunis dans une prise
d'otages dessine moi un alien et une
petite fille qui se fait buter par un
alien de d'en avoir fait un voeu
l'évolution des rêves d'un enfant qui
devient adulte minoré mon court métrage
qui a été tourné entièrement au japon
l'autre moi et si on rencontrait une
autre version de soi même qui avait fait
d'autres choix dans la vie et enfin
phone story un court métrage entièrement
du point de vue d'un smartphone voilà
dites moi dans les commentaires dans une
semaine les résultats